marco has millions of vehicles
if we go toe-to-toe with him we could
lose
just to give our fans a quick refresher
too i was hoping you could tell us where
your character
left off in season four and where we
find them in the beginning of season
five
we start with season five that amos
found out that somebody close to him
has died and he doesn't know how this
person has died but he knows that he
made a deal
with somebody in baltimore to keep her
safe
and so he's going back to find out if
how she died and if somebody mistreated
her and if so
then the grim reaper is coming to visit
i was hoping we could start off with the
both of you
quickly telling us where your character
left off you know at the end of season
four and where we find them at the
beginning of season
five we'll start um with you dominique
season four
kind of ends that was a whole thing
season four was quite a lot for naomi i
think in kind of
a very physical sense um and the
limits of her body which i don't think
she's ever really had to deal with
before
so going into season five although
season four was a whole thing
season five the top of it is quite
settled she's like
on taiko with holden you know the ship's
getting fixed they've got an apartment
it's all chill
and then fred finds her son and then i
think if you're
a viewer of the expense and stuff is
calm
you know some shit's about to go down so
we basically launch into naomi taking a
very
illogical choice to find and save her
son
as there's a bounty on marco's head and
she's worried that he's wrapped up in
that
and um it's it's i think delving into
anyone's past whether
you go and have therapy or you're
meeting someone that hurt you
is difficult but this is like next level
and
we have been planting seeds since season
one about naomi's past it's all been
kind of shrouded in secrecy
but now we get to see it full out and
it's open we get to find out everything
that happened
we get to find out why it was so
traumatic why it continues to be
and so it's just probably the most
beautiful kind of rewarding
um viewing but uh
quite traumatic for naomi as a character
very traumatic
thanks and you can what about marco well
in season four we see
marco as a very ballsy
um manipulative uh
freedom fighter and by the end of the
season
he's got the pieces in place to uh
to carry out his vision but what season
five brings
is all the the uh
wrenches get that get thrown into that
plan uh
including the uh meeting with his
ex-lover and baby mama who arrives at
the worst possible moment because she is
his kryptonite
and right when everything is going
according to plan
he also has to uh
reveal uh his his uh
weaknesses uh at the same time as trying
to
rule the universe and so the ride is
crazy it's
he he's very uncomfortable we're seeing
him
we're seeing him in a light that we've
never seen him we're seeing
the very um the heart of who he is as
opposed to just
the the stereotype of him as a leader or
the archetype of him as a freedom
fighter we're seeing
really what he's made of and what
happened in the past between
naomi and marco that has led each of
them down the trajectories that they've
gone on
and then to meet at this point with
philip
uh that they're fighting over is it's
it's pretty juicy
we wanted to give our fans sort of a
refresher to start so can you tell us
quickly tell us you know where your
character leaves off at the end of
season four
and where we find them at the beginning
of season five um
and let's start with kara uh so at the
end of season four drummer has parted
ways with the opa by way of a punch to
fred johnson's fat face
which is pretty final and she in the
time between season four and season five
she's found her uh a new crew
they have become family you find her in
a love relationship it's polyamorous
it is multi-faceted and queer and tender
and sexy and beautiful and
i think for about the first 30 seconds
of season five she is happy
and then it all goes to [ __ ]
with adversarial she is uh
at the end of season four we sort of
think oh my god
she has accepted her faith and she knows
that uh
her time is done and she sends that
lovely message
a dearly message to really cow
ask her to be herself and take as much
vacation as she can
do not sacrifice herself for her job
things that she should have told herself
when she was young but uh
and we feel like oh what what's
happening here
is she giving in no she's not she's
played this game
many times before what she's trying to
do
is to be as polite as courteous as
possible
and then get shut down
does trouble seem to find your
characters or
do your characters just love finding
trouble
in real life it's like my daughter
keeps saying do they find you or you
find them i'm like
vice versa it's a mutual feeling
people who are looking for truffle
obviously we'll come across them
what do you think i mean drummer is sort
of a pirate right so i think it's the
latter what do you think
cara i feel like she's kind of
minding her own business out there just
like casually in the live pirating
um and then things get really crazy on
her i don't know i feel like
uh i feel like that's why she stepped
away from the opa was because things
just were
were not she didn't believe in that she
didn't want that life anymore
i think she thought that she would
settle into like a quiet life of
you know piracy and
and be done with it so i don't think
she's expecting
as much uh trouble to come her way as
what what
what happens in season five that's for
sure you know we start off with holden
finally getting to take a break for a
change do you feel like
do you feel like he's happy staying put
or do you think he misses his crewmates
who basically become
family at this point he misses them
desperately you know i think
there is an irony uh in the beginning of
season five that you know we
through through holden's epic kind of
evolution from this idealistic young man
and when we first meet him in season one
to competent and solid leader at the
beginning of season five
throughout these horrible experiences
that he's been through
uh his family has been his rock you know
this the rossi crew has always been his
anchor
and he's finally arrived with his feet
on the floor
and then the rug of his family is pulled
out from under him and everyone scatters
across the system
and he takes this journey this season
alone and in many ways and um it's a
very different structure for us
it was a structure that i was looking
forward to having been a fan of
book five and something i was looking
forward to there's a lot of payoff for
things that have been cooking a long
time
um but a very different kind of journey
for holden this year
yeah totally different do you feel like
holden mrs miller
you know miller's basically this ghost
in his head now
does he does he miss miller are we gonna
get to see miller again
well i can't i can't say but um
there's a piece of holden that does you
know i think with miller
finally gone in totality
holden is really left with the
experience
of witnessing the rise and fall of
civilizations and speaking to the
proto-molecule and seeing these
terrifying
entities that ended their civilization
to himself he's got to hold that on his
own
and um you know he's he's capable of it
now it's not it's not about to break his
psyche anymore as it was in season three
and
he was more comfortable with with it in
season four
but now um you know he he's accepted his
place
uh within the universe so to speak and
he's accepted his responsibility and
he's able to take it
ironically his his i think the thing
he's most worried about this season
is getting back to his family you know
all of this
incredibly these catastrophic events
start happening uh and they're separate
he doesn't know if he's going to
see naomi again he doesn't know if
thickness is alive
he doesn't know any of that and you know
he's actually more apt and capable and
experienced in dealing with the
proto-molecule at this point
than he is being separated from them um
so it's a it's a very interesting
dynamic it's a different dynamic
and it was something i was looking
forward to playing this year yeah
it's almost like how i'm more used to
being in quarantine than i am being
around my friends now
that's my proto molecule you know what i
mean
that's right you've got a ship of your
own
a good crew someone who loves you and
you love
obviously you know this series follows
the books pretty closely but as
authors of the books how faithful do you
think it actually is to the books
i think it is just faithful enough and
not too faithful
yeah the the you know those are the two
dangers right uh
being not faithful at all you lose the
thing that made the uh the property
popular to begin with but slavish
devotion
to uh you know reproducing the text is
also a bad way to make a tv show or
learning uh the things that work in
print
often do not work on screen and you have
to be aware of what those things are and
make the adjustments
uh because it has to work as a tv show
right and i'm sure that's
kind of really hard to decide but you
guys just like nail it naren
why do you think season six is the
perfect place to stop
well season six and and book six have
have a point like that gives you a sort
of a natural ending
right it it it closes a chapter of the
story off
it leaves still there's a crack you know
uh
for for further things down the road
which are events of book 789
um and tying daniel and i for the last
several years
we had talked about various versions of
how to get through the material and one
of them was the six season
plan that ended in this way so it wasn't
something that we had to reformulate or
reframe or sort of scramble to get
through
we had this version in mind for some
time
okay well that's interesting to know but
obviously you know there's there's more
than six
books so do you guys all see like a
spin-off series coming out of this
a movie maybe it's a big world lots of
things could happen oh come on daniel
you've got to give me more than that
it would be pretty it could be very
pretty if that happened
it was it would be fun it would
certainly be fun our fans are super
excited to see the churnwest
coming to the show and i know so are you
because you've just been a fan for so
long you've read the books you've been
talking about this in interviews for a
while
um but for those that don't know i was
hoping that you could explain
what it means and why it's important to
see that brought to life
well for me this is a dream come true
when i first heard about the expanse
uh in in starting before episode one
season one they gave me a copy of the
churn and it is
amos's uh childhood it's a it's about
him growing up in baltimore and how he
got out of baltimore and the story
around that
and you really learn about why he is the
way he is what motivates him
um and so doing the work based off of
that book and that character that
in that book in every season revisiting
it four or five times i gave the book to
a psychologist and we like broke it down
like
the mental state and disassociative
disorder and and then going all the way
to season five where you actually this
thing that's been living in my
imagination
is now real it's not tanned we're now in
baltimore i'm having this conversation
with eric i get to hang out with peaches
and and explore that relationship and
you know as an as an actor
you don't get the kind of time to
prepare for something for six years
and then be able to to live in it and
and do it so it was just it was an
incredible experience
cara i feel like you know the crew is
like family to you in this show
but a lot of your relationships you know
drummer's relationships get challenged
so can you talk about a lot of the
different sides of drummer we're gonna
get to see this season
it's basically like the camera has come
into drummer's personal life i think and
so
it's a really really intimate look at um
at these relationships i think
especially
just to have drummer be in a love
relationship
is going to be just so powerful i think
um
especially for our queer fans like
i think there was so much around like
the drummer and naomi and shipping that
and just drummer not getting the girl
and
that's yeah that's just exhausting i
think to be
confronted with that storyline again and
again and again and so to see drummer
actually um you know in a thriving
healthy polyamorous relationship uh
oh yeah of course it's the nature of the
show nothing lasts forever but we're but
we'll
we're going to be with her in that
moment for a bit i think uh
to me that's just that's so important
it's so important and i think to get to
show that side of drummer
that is more human and more vulnerable
than we've ever seen
so far uh is really satisfying
dominique you know you brought up
phillip keon
so when you look at a character like
naomi she has such maternal tendencies
you know she
she has this relationship with holden
she's always taking care of amos
this show is very much about a family
dynamic what was it like to shift that
mindset for your character
to now she has to build this
relationship with her son
so so what was it like shifting that
mindset and how did that affect you
oh i don't think that naomi ever let go
of her maternal um kind of instinct i
think
if that's why she ended up kind of
having the relationship that she has
with amos and even holden to an extent
she does look after everyone and i think
when you watch
season five you get to find out why
it didn't continue with her son
and i think she's been trying to
kind of fill that gap um in other places
but um
yeah it it it doesn't quite go as as she
planned
and she has quite a naive approach to it
and i think for me
i mean there's two things there's the
kind of journey she's been on as naomi
and and what i just said about having
that maternal instinct
but then there's also me kind of me and
josiah who plays phillip
and first of all the costume is so
excellent he literally looks like
me and king song
imagination-wise it was very much like
this is my son and
i developed quite a maternal bond to
to him outside of people playing as
characters like
i mean both of us did there were times
we were at lunch and
i'd be like make sure you put your
jacket on and keon would be like do you
want me to take your plate and then we
were like
what are we doing but at the same time
there was just this very
quite instant bond as a family and we
looked like a family so it was just like
trippy
and so um but that just added to like
the scenes being so
rich and full of this like very
devastating
uh sun and mother energy and and i think
it really
brought something quite special to the
scenes and to the season
that i don't know if it would have been
there otherwise so yeah
i agree it's the worst when you're
watching something and that the sun
doesn't look like the dad or the mod
it's source
if you guys could go through a ring gate
what kind of planet would you like to
encounter or
vacay on i i would i would want to be
going on whichever one
was pointing towards here because i i
know uh
how well adapted humans are to earth and
how well
earth is adapted to humans i'm not going
anyplace else this is the place that has
all the coffee shops daniel's perfect
ring world
travel would take him right back to
albuquerque it's really sad
it's exactly back to his home i i guess
i would go to one with a lot of beaches
and uh and hope somebody had already set
up a margarita stand on the beach
see i told you we're talking to three
geniuses
you guys are hilarious you have
committed the entire belt to war with
the inners
they wanted to fight we'll give her one
would you ever want to see the expanse
turned into a video game and if so what
would that look like
i would love to see that you know i
think that what's great
the reason that the expanse has it
existed in books and existed in a
role-playing game exists in the tv
series
it's because it's a great story the
story is the the foundation
and if they put that into a video game i
think that could work just as well
there's so many stories and universes
just to tell within the expanse would
you guys ever like to see it turned into
a video game and if so what would that
look like
i would love for it to turn into a video
game i love doing video games
i've done destiny destiny 1 destiny 2
mass effect 1 mass effect 2
have you ever done video games no no
amazing they are just such fun
so i can totally see expanse turning
into a video game
and i would play it 24 7. oh my god
i like i play toon blast on my phone i
don't know anything about it i'm sorry
but i feel like
uh video games look like movies
i'm like way out of my depth talking
about it i should say nothing
[Laughter]
with so many universes in so many worlds
would you ever want to see
the expanse um turned into a video game
yeah why not yeah actually sure that'd
be great
i had to ask you stephen because you
know you are a fan of the books would
you ever want to see
the expanse turned into a video game and
if so what what would that look like
sure absolutely i mean you know i think
uh oh i'm not i'm not a huge gamer
myself but
um the ones that i always loved growing
up were the world building ones you know
and uh the ones that you can explore and
be in and
it's such a rich world that james s a
corey has built
and you know we've had the fortune of
having them in our writer's room they
write episodes they're there all the
time as executive producers
and we're all close friends so um you
know having them
and lorraine shankar guide this
adaptation uh
over the years um i have no doubt in my
mind
that if they were involved in adapting
it for a video game it would be killer
yeah it'd be kind of cool to see like
your character like in your game for me
that's right that's right it would be
amazing yeah it'd be a
kind of a existential event like you got
him to do all kinds of funny things and
stuff that would be fun
um you know obviously like you said
there's so many worlds to tell
so would you guys like to see there's so
many stories to tell so many worlds to
pull from
would you guys like to see the expanse
turned into a video game ty i know you
love this question so i'd love to start
with you
uh i i'd like to see it turn into a good
video game
um sure uh yeah
i mean if somebody wants to make a great
video game at the expense i'm all for it
i'm coming full circle yeah
that would that would actually be the
full circle as if somebody made a video
game out of you
and why is that well it started out as a
video game pitch
it just never uh it never succeeded as a
pitch for a video game and then
became books and tv shows and all the
other things it is now
so coming back around to uh being a
video game
yeah that would close the loop and then
i guess we can all just die or something
our work here on this earth is done
it's time to let the system know
who we are
[Music]
you